hey guys dr. Berg here in this short
video I'm going to talk about what's
really behind hormonal cystic acne okay
it can be very frustrating when I was a
teenager I had really bad acne and I
didn't know how to get rid of it
so I would try creams and lotions and
put it on my face and scrub the acne it
never would work ok little did I know it
was hormonal
okay so there's two main reasons why
this occurs and I'll give you some
solutions to number one especially if
you're female you could have polycystic
ovarian syndrome okay that's a condition
where you're making too much male
hormone testosterone and you might be
getting facial hair deeper voice weight
gain
definitely acne and that really what's
behind that is high levels of insulin a
lot of times to talk about pause cystic
ovarian syndrome being associated with
high insulin or insulin resistance
mendelian and mmm it's caused by high
insulin and insulin resistance okay so I
put a link down below on that video if
you want to learn a little bit more
about insulin resistance and how to
lower that and there's a lot of things
you can do and it's you can get some
seriously good results with that okay so
that's one thing but there's an enzyme
that converts testosterone into what's
called DHT the very powerful form of
testosterone which is causing the acne
and it's called 5-alpha reductase okay
so it's a fancy word for just an enzyme
that converts these two and in certain
people you just have too much of that
enzyme so what you want to do is you
want to take a 5 alpha reductase
inhibitor alright you want to take a
natural one and that happens to be in
all the cruciferous foods okay they can
the broccoli the brussel sprouts the
cabbage that really really helps but
there's a very concentrated form of
cruciferous called dim I'm not going to
give you the long name for it but two
tablets of dim is equivalent to two
pounds of cruciferous vegetables so I'll
show you I use this for my clients
called estrogen balance with dim
okay it has 200 milligrams of them and
you don't want to take more than that
because if you take too much it can
create more acne so you just want just
enough and I put a lot of other things
to help balance estrogen and associated
things like cruciferous vegetables okay
so you may want to if you're interested
in checking it out I put a link down
below you can get more information but
that's what you need to help stop this
conversion to really get rid of the acne
all right I hope that helped now see in
the next video hey guys thank you so
much for watching please click the
subscribe button and I will see you in
the next video